vraiment on va commencer par ça
messieurs puisque effectivement plein
milieu de votre élection il y aura ce
débat au Parlement mardi prochain
l'Assemblée le mardi suivant au Sénat un
projet de loi sera présenté l'année
prochaine rend plus efficace les
occuts leur rendre la vie impossible
c'est ce que dit Gérald Darmanin
inscrire les immigrés menacés
d'expulsion au fichiers des personnes
recherchées est-ce que vous pourriez
voter ce texte Stéphane
c'est que le texte était annoncé pour
fin de l'année
et deux semaines en semaine on est en
train de reculer sur ce fameux texte sur
l'immigration qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire
tout simplement que
la souveraineté nationale est en péril
par rapport à l'immigration on l'a vu
avec le fameux épisode de San Viking ou
l'Europe a été incapable de régler la
problématique sur les aucutés f en tant
que tel 6% d'exécution en 2021 on a
véritablement une souveraineté juridique
qui est partie à Bruxelles où on peut
malheureusement plus avoir la destinée
des vagues migratoires et de la
régulation de l'ensemble des personnes
qui arrivent sur le territoire que
faut-il faire Bruno retaille ou le dit
vous pouvez tout promettre si vous ne
faites pas un référendum sur la base de
l'article 11 de la Constitution ce sont
les juges européens qui casseront les
textes qui viendront au Parlement donc
la réponse elle est très claire fermeté
mise en place de quota migratoire
révision
du droit du regroupement familial du
droit du sol en fait clairement tout ce
qu'on n'a pas fait depuis 30 ans tout ce
qui était dans la convention de la
droite en 1991 donc ce texte est pas
suffisant pour vous moi j'attends
j'attends avoir le contenu du texte
puisqu'on nous le promet de semaine en
semaine encore une fois on nous
l'annonce pour mars peut-être que ça
sera pour juillet l'année prochaine
est-ce que les républicains doivent être
aux côtés du Gouvernement sur ce texte
écoutez je pense qu'on aura aucune
difficulté d'avoir une position sur ce
texte parce que c'est pas un texte qui
vise à réduire l'immigration ou lutter
contre l'immigration illégale ou
renvoyer dans les pays d'origine les
étrangers frappés d'une obligation de
quitter le territoire français le texte
dont on entend qu'il va nous être
présenté semble plutôt être un texte de
régularisation massive à des fins de
travail je veux dire ce qu'on comprend
de ce texte aujourd'hui c'est plutôt une
logique de régularisation massive c'est
Olivier du soft qui finalement est au
pilotage de ce texte plus qu'un texte
d'application de notre droit après
la partie plus dure oui enfin quand on
commence en disant la première des
priorités ça va être de régulariser de
façon très massive ça pose un préalable
dans notre incapacité à voter ce texte
mais aujourd'hui je crois que c'est ce
qu'on porte avec avec Aurélien Pradier
il faut arrêter avec la droite bavarde
sur ces sujets là il faut arrêter de
faire des grands discours de monter de
gonfler les pectoraux il faut agir agir
c'est déjà appliquer notre droit c'est
exécuter les aucutf aujourd'hui le souci
c'est l'exécution des octuf c'est pas
toujours des des problèmes de de de
juridiction européenne d'ailleurs c'est
rarement Bruxelles c'est plutôt les
juridictions qui relèvent de l'autre
construction européenne que celle de
l'Union européenne qui interviennent sur
ses sujets d'immigration on va pas faire
exposé sur sur un petit mot après je
vous donne la parole simplement très
rapidement la priorité des priorités
c'est l'exécution des auqtf et c'est là
dessus que nous avons des propositions
fortes avec Aurélien juste je fais
réagir à l'injean et puis après vous
vous répondez à
feltchelenbergouv
pour l'instant les journaux donc on a
tendance ce texte que je veux dire sur
ce sujet là au moins une chose qui est
claire c'est qu'avec Eric Ciotti c'est
clair ça fait plus de 10 ans que dit des
choses qui aujourd'hui deviennent des
choses naturelles alors qu'il était le
seul à le dire et notamment quand il
parlait de la relation évidente entre
l'immigration clandestine et puis les
problèmes de sécurité parce que vous
rappelez des des tollés que ça pouvait
entraîner aujourd'hui on voit bien que
plus on arrive à la fin cette campagne
pour la présidence des républicains on
voit bien que les autres candidats
reviennent tous sur les positions de de
d'Éric Ciotti donc et qui fait
d'ailleurs des propositions qui sont pas
nouvelles c'est pas l'occasion de cette
élection le droit du sang à la place du
droit du sol c'est pas depuis hier
l'expulsion au qtf les difficultés de
clef je vais pas rentrer dans le débat
c'est tellement technique la fin du reg
familial la fin de l'aide médicale
d'État à l'ennemique l'aide médicale
d'État j'ai été porteur de ce texte ici
au Sénat je rappelle que c'est les
médicaments pour les immigrés en
situation irrégulière irrégulière
qu'avec Nicolas Sarkozy nous avions
divisé par deux
Eric fioti travaille déjà au côté des
richiotiques quand il était député il a
fait d'ailleurs on n'a pas fait que du
bavardage avec Éric Ciotti on a fait
voter des textes que Monsieur Hollande
et dans la foulée monsieur Macron ont
supprimé donc avec erisiotti sur ce sur
ce sujet là j'irai à la limite il y a
même pas besoin de parler de son
programme tellement les gens connaissent
bien oui juste je vais réagir Alain il
faut être honnête aussi sur
l'immigration on a mis effectivement
place les peines penchées et dans le
même temps on supprime la double peine
c'est un message contradictoire dans le
cas du du quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy
il y a eu des choses qui ont été bien
faites et il y a des choses qui ont été
mal faites là aussi on doit avoir
parce que il y a encore il y a encore
quelques semaines quelques mois nous
étions tous les deux tous les trois tous
les deux au côté d'érectionti mais tous
les deux avec toi au côté direction type
pour vanter question le seul programme
qui allait bien c'est celui d'Éric
Ciotti aujourd'hui tu es le porte-parole
d'un autre candidat c'est très bien je
suis tout ça dans nos dans nos
concitoyens veulent plus quoi les gens
qui changent de partie toutes les 5
minutes
j'attaque pas le projet tu m'as mal
compris ce que je veux dire par là là la
différence que nous avons c'est qu'à un
moment donné nous avons un droit
d'inventaire par rapport à ce que nous
avons fait dans les années où nous
étions au gouvernement tant qu'on a pas
je ne bat pas ma coupe ce qu'on a fait
quand on est au pouvoir c'était beaucoup
mieux alors on ne sera pas après tout
fait on n'a pas tout faire beaucoup
mieux bon on ne sera pas crédible voilà
ce droit d'inventaire je reparle de
l'immigration des années Sarkozy des
années c'est les années la différence
juste un instant puis après je je tourne
un peu merci juste à l'instant plutôt
que de dire les uns tournant la page
Sarkozy les autres si Sarkozy on est
d'accord si Sarkozy s'en va je sais où
vous êtes d'accord mais moi je suis pas
d'accord et Eric ciottier non plus
plutôt que de dire tournons la page
Sarkozy d'abord pour tourner une page il
faut que quelque chose soit écrit dessus
alors quand les autres candidats
voudront tourner leur page il faudra
qu'ils aient écrit une page et avec
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est pas une page c'est
un livre plutôt que de on ne construis
jamais l'avenir en réunion notre passé
plutôt que de vouloir tancer en
permanence Nicolas Sarkozy essayons
plutôt je termine essayons plutôt
essayons plutôt de bien savoir comment
il a fait pour être président de la
République pour renvoyer le Front
national à 7%, si nous arrivions à faire
aussi bien la prochaine fois alors là on
pourrait peut-être tourner la page
Sarkozy
simplement
c'est intéressant de voir comment on
peut
s'interpeller entre nous pour des choses
sur lesquelles on est à priori quand
même d'accord je crois que c'est bien là
l'enjeu de cette élection c'est d'aller
de l'avant et de regarder l'avant façon
pragmatique objective en revenant en
revenant à nos valeurs la droite que
nous portons n'est pas une droite
inhumaine et sur cette question de
l'immigration il faut être très clair
les propositions d'érections sont
constantes c'est vrai mais elles sont
pas toutes opérantes aujourd'hui sur la
question de l'immigration par exemple le
combat d'érectionis c'est l'augmentation
du nombre de places en centre de
rétention administrative or on sait très
bien aujourd'hui que ça n'est pas ça qui
permet
notre capacité à expulser au contraire
ça ne permet que de stocker des auqtf
sans les exécuter réellement ce sur quoi
nous voulons agir ça n'est pas stocké ça
n'est pas créé des places de CRA qui
sont particulièrement chers c'est très
simplement et efficace renvoyer les
étrangers en situation irrégulière dans
leur pays d'origine un dernier mot c'est
fanion
parce que tu vois si tu avais bien vécu
le débat
entre les trois candidats tu m'aurais
dit quand même le Sénat était attaqué
et ça ça me plaît pas parce que je suis
sénateur dans le coeur comme tu me l'as
toujours dit j'étais député aussi tu
sais que tu viens de là et tu es revenu
là et j'ai trouvé ça quand même et ça
fait l'assemblée
parce que je suis indépendant ce que
j'attends pas après
quand on nous dit qu'on a mal travaillé
sur les vigées ou c'est des énergies
renouvelables quand même il faut
l'entendre ça non oui j'entends tout
mais j'entends aussi ceux qui me disent
et je suis d'accord avec eux que le
Sénat a besoin d'être profondément
renouvelé les malades
je suis allé à la droite du Assemblée
nationale et j'ai fait deux fois le
Sénat et je dis oui je dis que dans dans
notre pays le Sénat on aura ça sera
l'occasion d'un autre débat mais je
pense que le Sénat effectivement a
besoin d'être on pas voter des lois
puisse excuser un mois après parce que
parce qu'on se rend compte qu'elles sont
pas bonnes je rappelle ce qu'on a fait
sur le covid bah oui on a voté le pas
sanitaire puis après en même temps on a
voté une commission d'enquête
et si on veut faire une action
sur le terrain
puisque tu es favorable aux
introspections faisant celles aussi du
Sénat un mot rapidement
le Sénat on a eu un débat je crois que
les sur un certain nombre de sujets
Stéphane la cité l'IVG l'éolien nous
avons des accords c'est comme ça c'est
pas la peine de de s'échapper comme des
chiffonniers il faut juste pouvoir se
dire les choses ce qu'on veut
aujourd'hui c'est construire une droite
attractive ambitieuse qui redonne envie
aux Français on peut pas s'enfermer dans
dans des débats en s'interpellant en
permanence et vouloir redonner envie aux
Français de nous écouter c'est un
message comporte avec Aurélien Pradier
justement on va parler d'un sujet sur
lequel la droite est attendue c'est la
réforme des retraites Elisabeth Borny en
était devant les députés elle maintient
a priori son calendrier 65 ans a fait le
chilenberger est-ce que c'est une
réforme qui doit être soutenue par les
républicains écoutez je crois que sur ce
sujet là il faut que les républicains on
en reviennent de nos fondamentaux mais
fondamentaux c'est d'abord défendre le
travail et avant tout le travail la
réforme que propose madame borne c'est
la réforme de la facilité qui prend les
vêtements d'une forme de courage sans
sans réalité derrière la vraie courage
c'est de d'écouter ceux qui travaillent
c'est d'entendre que 10% de nos
retraités aujourd'hui arrivent à la
retraite en situation d'invalidité c'est
d'entendre que quand on agit sur le seul
âge comme critère de départ à la
retraite en réalité on va demander à
ceux qui travaillent déjà le plus de
faire des efforts supplémentaires sans
regarder la société qui a changé sans
regarder la réalité de ce que vivent les
Français bien sûr sur les territoires
donc la réforme telle que nous la
propose à Madame borne c'est simplement
de dire voyez être courageux quand on
gouverne c'est prendre des mesures
impopulaires non être courageux quand on
gouverne c'est écouter les Français
c'est faire des diagnostics clairs il y
a pas d'urgence absolue aujourd'hui pas
du tout réformer les retraites il faut
réformer les retraites il faut toucher à
l'âge de départ il faut remettre j'ai
pas j'ai pas j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit
qu'il faut remettre au coeur du débat au
cœur du débat le travail nous proposons
avec Aurélien Pradier qu'au cœur du
débat ce soit la durée de cotisation
vous savez toutes ces carrières
interrompues
c'est pas flou cher Alain vous savez les
effets de manche les effets de manche et
les phrases qui permettent de faire des
tweets y compris au Sénat ce n'est pas
forcément ce qui permet de construire
des réformes solides aujourd'hui la
société a changé les carrières chez un
seul employeur c'est fini aujourd'hui
les carrières sont coupées parfois avec
parfois avec des périodes de non travail
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut travailler
je crois qu'aujourd'hui la priorité des
priorités c'est de travailler sur la
durée de cotisation non il ne faut pas
toucher à l'âge les gars de départ là
écoutez ça aurait été bien qu'on entend
de les propositions de Bruno
mais c'est parce que parce que la
propositions la proposition d'érectionis
c'est un mixte c'est un mixte donc bon
ce qui suivent les débats de cette
présidentielle elle est le savent
justement
sur une partie des choses et notamment
sur le fait que comme les situations des
futurs retraités sont très différentes
les unes des autres c'est très compliqué
de régler le problème avec une seule
solution et c'est pour ça que Eric
Ciotti a imaginé quelque chose
d'ailleurs qui a été évalué et qui a été
plutôt bien noté par les spécialistes
qui est de dire pour certains l'âge
légal
ce sera très bien et pour d'autres qui
ont notamment commencé
très tôt dans le travail ceux qui ont
commencé comme apprentis par exemple là
je poserai un problème et donc là on
prend la durée de cotisation mais dans
les deux cas pour que les choses soient
claires que ce soit pas flou il faudra
travailler plus c'est clair il faudrait
le projet d'Éric ciotisme c'est 10
milliards d'économies par an pour sauver
le régime des retraites si les retraités
actuels veulent ne pas voir leur pension
de retraite baissée il faut que
l'assiette de cotisation soit plus large
donc on peut avoir des débats sur la
meilleure solution technique pour y
arriver mais en tout état de cause le
courage la vérité c'est de dire à ceux
qui travaillent aujourd'hui c'est vous
qui êtes porteur des retraits de vos
parents de vos grands-parents qui sont
aujourd'hui
légitimement en train de se reposer et
pour que ce soit bien clair dans la
positionner avec ce type là je légale de
départ C65 ans et la durée de cotisation
c'est entre 43 et 48 le tout c'est très
important de le dire avec une
progressivité parce qu'on va pas passer
immédiatement 62 à 65 et puis je suis
tenté de dire quand même que les
politiques ne peuvent pas tout on peut
annoncer un certain nombre de grands
principes mais une chose qui est
absolument fondamentale c'est de le
laisser les partenaires sociaux
s'entretenir négocier dans un cadre vous
savez ça a toujours été comme ça on
laisse les partenaires sociaux quand les
partenaires sociaux ne réussissent plus
à s'entendre à ce moment-là le
législateur intervient mais je pense que
la solution d'ericsiotis c'est la
solution pragmatique qui correspond à la
réalité du terrain vous entendez ça
Stéphane laurier pour Bruno retaille
favorable à une réforme des retraites et
la à raison je pense qu'il faut dire la
vérité aux Français on a tellement fait
de proposition de promesses parfois
irréaliste que si on dit l'inverse on
décevra une muette quoi qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé sous le premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron il y a 8 millions
de retraités qui ont perdu du pouvoir
d'achat donc oui à une réforme de
retraite SA garantit de nouveau droit
garantir de nouveaux droits c'est quoi
c'est une retraite au minimum à 1200
euros par mois tout le monde a
connaissance de certaines pensions à
moins de 900 voire 800 euros alors que
la personne a travaillé
longtemps très longtemps voire même 47
ans parfois et puis sur l'âge
légal effectivement il faut un filet de
sécurité sinon si on ne prend que la
durée de cotisation ça peut créer une
injustice sociale mais sur cette durée
de cotisation il faut y travailler
également par rapport à la pénibilité et
pénibilité du travail donc une certaine
forme de barrelisation et dernier point
on peut pas demander uniquement une
frange de français des efforts si on
doit faire une réforme des retraites il
faut aussi parler des 42
régime spéciaux et de cette réforme de
ces régimes spéciaux derrière ça juste
un dernier mot on a 15
à 45 milliards dépend la Cour des
comptes a du mal à évaluer de fraude
sociale en France on parle de réforme de
retraite à 10 milliards 15 milliards par
an je pense que nous devons l'État doit
impérativement lutter contre cette
fraude sociale parce qu'on peut pas
demander des efforts offensés et en même
temps laisser ouvert ses vannes sur la
fraude sociale c'est la raison pour
laquelle le Sénat a d'ailleurs mis en
oeuvre et dans le cadre du pfss
cette carte biométrique au niveau de la
carte vitale qui pourrait résorber pas
mal de fraude sociale juste un mot pour
dire que la dernière belle réforme des
retraites qui a permis de sauver le
système en passant 60 à 62 il faut
encourageuses c'est Nicolas Sarkozy 9
jours de grève 9 jours de grève
seulement donc le courage le courage et
donc je dis juste ça parce que si ça
n'avait pas été fait à l'époque si ça
n'a pas été fallait pas aujourd'hui les
retraités auraient une une pension de
retraite alors beaucoup beaucoup plus
diminué et ça n'a pas au départ ça a été
médiatiquement compliqué et au final au
final le courage politique l'a emporté
le courage d'une réforme politique c'est
pas ça se mesure pas à la quantité de de
nombre de grévistes ou au nombre de
jours de grève ça se mesure cher Alain
je t'écoute
c'est peut-être aussi ça la nouvelle
droite c'est une droite qui s'écoute le
courage c'est la justice de de la
réforme la droite elle doit être juste
et le sujet aujourd'hui c'est celui-là
quand on voit le Sénat qui depuis des
années considère que la réforme de la
retraite est finalement le facteur
d'ajustement des dépenses nouvelles
qu'on crée dans le projet de loi de
finance des sécurités sociales et qu'on
fait finalement de cet amendement
technique d'ajustement un totem de
réforme sans jamais reprendre le temps
de réfléchir ça fait 10 ans qu'à droite
on agit par automatisme ça fait 10 ans
qu'on a pris plus pris le temps de
réfléchir ça fait 10 ans qu'on propose
les mêmes solutions aux Français sans
que jamais on arrive à se faire
comprendre des Français c'est bien ça le
message qu'on porte il est temps de
travailler à nouveau il est temps de
réfléchir il est temps de sortir des
automatismes pour revenir à nos valeurs
et proposer un projet ambitieux aux
Français qui nous écoutent si je peux me
permettre il y a quand même une réalité
démographique les enfants qui naissent
aujourd'hui en 2022 ont une espérance de
vie de 90 à 93 ans
et on peut soutenir encore qu'on
travaillera toujours dans la même durée
légale le sait après ces responsabilités
pour évoquer trois ou quatre sujets
la pyramide la pyramide des âges ça
n'est pas seulement l'allongement la
durée de vie c'est aussi une évolution
forte de de la pyramide des âges avec
une génération importante qui
aujourd'hui est à la retraite et qui
progressivement c'est la vie plus rien
que bien que la durée de vie s'allonge
la durée de vanille fait que
on va verser plus longtemps des pensions
une des réalités démographiques de notre
pays on va passer au dernier thème de ce
sujet il est important c'est l'avenir du
parti est-ce que d'abord il y a un
baromètre au doxa qui a été fait pour
les chaînes parlementaires et la presse
régionale 73% des sympathisants les
républicains souhaitent une alliance on
parle des sympathisants pas des
militants à 73% est une alliance 45%
avec la majorité présidentielle 38% avec
le rassemblement national est-ce que
l'avenir des républicains passe toujours
par son autonomie à l'injeanet en tout
cas l'avenir des républicains passent
sans doute par son indépendance par son
renforcement vous savez on ne peut pas
discuter avec un partenaire si on ne
représente plus rien parce que c'est il
faut quand même le rappeler avant de
discuter avec éventuellement avec des
partenaires il faut quand même être
consolidé représenter quelque chose et
être intéressant pour les pour les
partenaires et pour les Français
pour vous je ne parle pas d'alliance je
parle d'indépendance de notre famille
politique et je dis que quel que soit
l'avenir moi je pense aux élections
présidentielles parce que au fond ce qui
nous importe puisqu'on est sur le
chapitre de qu'est-ce qui va se passer
dans le parti sur la stratégie ce qui
est important c'est l'élection
présidentielle parce que tout ce qu'on
raconte tout ce qu'on dit tous les
projets qu'on peut avoir et non
absolument aucune chance d'être
appliquée s'il y a pas une incarnation
c'est comme ça c'est la cinquième
république avec la présidentialisation
le quinquennat la version du calendrier
si vous perdez la présidentielle vous
avez tout perdu pendant 5 ans vous
pouvez faire des projets vous pouvez
discuter vous pouvez faire des débats
aucune chance de pouvoir s'en sortir
donc avec
Eric Ciotti sur l'organisation du parti
sur la stratégie là encore les choses
sont claires
s'il est élu président ce que je
souhaite il proposera à notre famille
politique de soutenir un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle il proposera
Laurent Wauquiez pour que les choses
soient claires le plus vite possible
j'ai dit je crois sur ce plateau lors
des dernières présidentielles que
l'erreur majeure que nous avions faites
avec été de désigner un candidat au
présidentiel quelques mois avant on a
désigné au mois de décembre pour une
élection au mois d'avril un candidat à
la présidentielle il faut qu'il ait
trois ou quatre ans devant lui et pour
moi c'est quelque chose d'absolument
capital sur l'avenir de notre famille
politique si nous n'avons pas d'ailleurs
j'en reviens à pardonné pardonnez-moi je
reviens l'élection 2007 mais s'il y
avait pas eu une incarnation en 2007 on
n'entrait pas l'Élysée l'incarnation
c'était Nicolas Sarkozy incarnation
qu'on soit clair c'est le candidat à la
présidentielle pas le président du parti
si vous n'avez pas dans une famille
politique de gouvernement si vous n'avez
pas une incarnation quelqu'un qui a
l'image d'un présidentiable vous pouvez
faire tout ce que vous voulez et il faut
l'avoir suffisamment longtemps à
l'avance je note qu'avec les les
puisqu'on est comme là pour confronter
les différentes stratégies je note
qu'avec les autres candidats à la
présidence on sait pas vraiment ce qui
va se passer sur ce sur ce plan là et
donc je suis impatient de l'entendre
juste c'est bien que tu fasses référence
à l'un Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007 parce
qu'il a été élu par les militants
qu'on est d'accord 14 janvier 2007 nous
on veut simplement reprendre ce qu'a
fonctionné ce que propose Éric ciotype
les primaires
la
propositions on en parle plus Alain j'ai
cru comprendre que c'était le Bureau
politique qui désignait le candidat mais
j'ai du mal comprendre les propositions
d'Eric non on a deux points un problème
de calendrier de divergence sur le
calendrier et un problème par rapport
aux modalités de désignation de notre
candidat les primaire on les a évacués
de notre règlement des républicains les
primaires ouvertes ont été évacuées on a
un machin qui a conduit à ce qu'on fasse
c'est simplement que les militants en
fait rendent la parole aux militants
pour désigner le candidat
je finis juste tout à l'heure tu disais
laissez-nous de nous écouter donc si tu
m'interromps enchères Stéphane là
pas du tout flou entretenu par ton
candidat pas non pas du tout il y a pas
de flou ah si mais il y a pas de flou ah
si plus de primaire ouverte vous
répondrez évidemment la parole aux
militants pour désigner le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle vous savez
Sarkozy disait une chose très vraie toi
qui est un nidolâtre de Sarko il disait
si on arrive pas à rassembler sa famille
politique
Sarkozy ce matin même toi dis donc bien
sûr si il y a des choses bien et comme
il y a des choses moins bien si on
n'arrive pas à rassembler sa famille
politique on n'est pas capable de
rassembler les Français donc problème
sur la désignation nous on veut rendre
la parole aux militants puis problème de
calendrier
eric veut impérativement désigner
Laurent très vite après l'élection du
président de notre famille politique il
y a un gros il y a un souci majeur qui
est le leader naturel de la droite
républicaine le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle ou le président du parti
deuxième élément il y a des élections
nous avons il y a des élections
intermédiaires il y a des élections
intermédiaires comme les annoncent de la
candidature à la candidature à la
présidentielle de Bruno retaille c'est
une obsession chez vous messieurs de
savoir si Bruno Retailleau sera Candy je
pense qu'il a répondu très clairement
dans le cas du débat il n'est candidat
qu'à la présidence des républicains
c'est juste un problème de clarté par
rapport à une stratégie c'est tout les
qualités
si vous désignez le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle d'une part on
va faire comme eux pendant 10 ans on va
oublier de réfléchir
quelqu'un dit tout à l'heure il y a une
paresse intellectuelle de la droite
depuis 10 ans c'est vrai d'abord le
corpus idéologique travaillons sur le
corpus hydoïque sur les choix
stratégiques à mettre en oeuvre un
nouveau projet si on pouvait parler de
propositions
c'est très clair je crois que il y a pas
de sujet là dessus on supprime tous les
machins qui sont dans nos statuts qui
sont des règles qui qui nous conduisent
à faire à chaque fois moins à l'élection
présidentielle plus de primaire ouverte
plus de primaire fermée plus de bidules
de départage on a un bureau politique on
le compose de façon à ce que ce soit lui
qui travailler au rassemblement parce
que ça suffit aussi pour les militants
d'avoir un bureau politique on ne nomme
que des chapeaux à plumes qui ne
représentent en rien la réalité de ce
que nos militants attendent sur le
terrain de ce que nous adhérents nous
disent chaque soir en réunion publique
ces derniers temps c'est le Bureau
politique qui propose un candidat les
militants qui ratifient à deux ans de
l'élection présidentielle c'est pas euh
c'est pas innovant c'est comme ça qu'on
gagne les illusions
c'est très bien c'est le modèle chinois
c'est pas du tout le modèle politique à
la chinoise c'est le fonctionnement du
RPR c'est le nom du RPR
Jacques Chirac est passé par la
désignation des militants c'est une
plaisanterie après là aussi il était
président du RPR faut pas réécrire les
choses est-ce que Bruno Retailleau a
l'intention de se présenter à l'élection
sollicité mais c'est une question à
laquelle il n'a pas répondu mais si je
crois que Eric vous avez mal Aurélien
ont été très clair là-dessus il n'a pas
répondu à aucun seul objectif c'est
d'être président des républicains ils
peuvent vouloir être candidat à la
présidentielle mais il faut le dire il
faut le dire on va pas dire ce qu'il a
pas envie de dire
un mot les amis sur sur le vécu parce
que on peut on peut comment dire parler
de souvenirs de ce qui va se passer ou
de ce qui va ne pas se passer moi une
chose qui me paraît claire pour tous les
présidents de la 5ème république
regardez ce qui s'est passé ils ont pas
été désignés un an avant deux ans avant
ils ont été président d'une famille
politique ils ont ils ont été cabossés
ils ont ils ont perdu des élections
avant d'en gagner un présidentiable
c'est comme ça et quand vous avez le PN
vous avez Mélenchon et vous avez Macron
qui est là depuis 15 ans vous mettez pas
un petit jeune qui arrive six mois avant
ou un an ou deux ans avant quand je dis
un petit jeune je parle du petit jeune
au sens de du temps de présence dans le
combat des présidentielles il faut
pouvoir faire partie du carré le carré
et les Français adorent ça les Français
c'est leur rendez-vous c'est pour ça
qu'ils vont voter à la présidentielle
ils veulent départager les Formule 1
voilà et on fait pas un grand prix de
Formule 1 avec un formules une formule 2
ou une formule 3000 vous voyez donc il
faut une Formule 1 et une formule 1
écurie sur la une écurie de Formule 1 et
bien ça ça se prépare longtemps à
l'avance et Emmanuel Macron lui et je
dis que tous ceux qui nous ont raconté
tous ceux qui nous ont raconté
commençons par les idées commençons par
les projets etc depuis qu'on fait ça on
perd les élections et quand on avait un
présidentiable et bien on gagne les
élections
Jacques Chirac on a travaillé sur le
fond avant de travailler
combien de temps avant avant d'être élu
François Mitterrand Hollande etc puis
juste un dernier mot mon cher ami dans
une France moderne qui est pas forcément
porté par des petits jeunes par des
legionnisme moi moi je vois que je
connais beaucoup de vieux qui sont
beaucoup plus jeunes que les petits
jeunes le le et bien oui c'est sûr et
donc moi je pense que le génisme c'est
pas un truc qui qui est séduisant pour
les gens et par contre ce que je pense
c'est que dans une société
modernement on a parlé de Johnny parce
que tu dis tout à l'heure la nouvelle
génération celle qui s'écoute etc
c'est les gens qui s'écoutent c'est des
gens qui s'écoutent qui débattent et
pour moi c'est absolument
invraisemblable dans une famille
politique d'imaginer que le militant il
aura pas son mot à dire ah ben je te
remercie c'est moderne c'est moderne
c'est une société horizontale c'est pas
une société verticale c'est une société
horizontale on peut pas faire adhérer
les gens sans leur demander leur avis
avec Nicolas Sarkozy on travaillait sur
les sujets disent sur chaque sujet
donc l'avenir est aussi beaucoup dans le
passé dans ce qu'on a tellement bien
fait voyez c'est symptomatique de ce qui
se passe à droite on a beaucoup parlé du
passé on s'écharpe sur nos règles
internes on a parlé d'immigration et de
et de et de et de retraite mais juste on
n'a pas répondu à une question quelle
est qu'elle sera un rapport avec
Emmanuel Macron pour le 13 la première
question qui m'a été posée
permettez-moi de répondre à la première
question avant avant d'en poser une
seconde moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que
la droite elle repart le français qu'on
parle des sujets qui l'un des intéresse
évidemment l'immigration évidemment les
retraites est-ce qu'on aurait pas pu
prendre un peu de temps pour parler
d'éducation pour parler d'environnement
voilà des sujets sur lesquels il faut
qu'on aille voilà des sujets sur
lesquels il faut que la droite elle
parle si la droite elle a l'ambition de
reparler aux Français si la droite elle
a l'ambition de revenir au pouvoir elle
doit parler de tout et à tous et on doit
revenir à tous les sujets qui
intéressent les Français et pas
seulement sur le petit pré carré des
sujets sur lesquels on s'est laissé
cantonner ces dernières années c'est
bien ça l'ambition que nous avons avec
32 minutes un mot chacun justement sur
la ligne du parti quelle ligne quelles
alliances et est-ce que vous resterez au
parti quel que soit le candidat voilà je
vais regarder en commentaire depuis que
j'ai 18 ans donc je me pose pas de
question je dirais
conclusion je veux juste vous dire un
petit mot c'est qu'avec Eric Ciotti on
le voit bien sur tous les sujets qu'on a
abordé ce matin les choses sont claires
et depuis longtemps donc on ne se pose
pas de questions il y a rien de flou et
pour l'avenir du parti aussi bien sur le
fond que sur la stratégie les choses
sont très claires avec lui et depuis
longtemps au fond erikiotti c'est un peu
c'est un peu une force tranquille de
droite quoi que qui est rassurante je
crois que c'est son tour
ni une droite de boutifier enfermé dans
ses propres torpeurs ni une droite de
salon une droite qui reparle aux
Français qui redonne de l'espérance qui
parle de tout qui propose un projet qui
est l'ambition de gouverner et Stéphanie
non moi je regrette dans dans le cadre
du congrès qu'on n'est pas assez parlé
de l'organisation du parti parce que
effectivement toutes les propositions
qu'on peut faire sur l'immigration sur
le régalien puis au-delà des sujets qui
nous intéressent sur logement la
décentralisation ou autre effectivement
ça n'a pas de sens si on n'est pas au
pouvoir donc 4 ans et sur l'organisation
du parti il y a un seul mot d'ordre pour
Bruno Retailleau c'est de rendre la
parole aux militants tout simplement
merci messieurs merci
[Musique]